lanier i'm just pulling up your board
here uh this tournament
now this game ended in a draw after a
big struggle this tournament didn't seem
to be yours as you had some
opportunities starting with round one
against fabian caruana but it didn't go
your way
yeah i mean i was just uh missing so
many uh opportunities that it's it's
really hard to
to win a tournament like this of course
so i i think i was mostly just playing
badly i'm
i had great positions and i somehow
was not able to
uh
to to
to just win some games so
yeah today i think again i had a big
advantage at some point
um
even after i uh play knight d5 takes
takes it's
quite dangerous for him and
uh i think i should have played this
rookie one rookie six and put up on e6
instead of uh taking the pawn on d4 oh
exactly what moment lanier here yeah i
think after uh bishop c4 king d6
probably rookie one rook uh rookie eight
and rookie six takes pawn takes and this
is very unpleasant for black i guess
with this uh point
six
so
in this case you're not winning the
bishop and king g2 yeah i think uh this
was better than what i did in the game
because here i'm
i'm not
upper pawn but uh i think the pawn is
six is very strong so it should be
uh good chances maybe not winning but um
it's a nice advantage you know got you
you
uh
we've seen a lot of players come in and
say we're tired we played so much online
chess we played so much over-the-board
chess as well as over the borches came
back you did play in the singfield cup
the rapid and blitz
and also the chest 960 right
so
with the fact that online chess is not
going to go away it looks like a fixture
here to stay how are you guys going to
balance
this schedule
yeah it's so
on the one hand it's nice to have like
tournaments all the time so i guess
you just have to be careful try to
to
arrange your schedule in a way that uh
you
don't get to i mean you don't play too
much
but uh but i like to have a lot of stuff
to to play can you afford to say no to
these tournaments the the money is
getting much better and great
opportunities that you haven't seen 10
years ago
yeah no definitely nice to to have all
these chances uh i guess at some point
you have to
uh
you have to say no to something for
example i didn't want to play the grand
chess swiss
which is just
right now like in a week or something
because i i knew i would be completely
um
finished after this one after all these
tournaments and i could already feel
um
at the end that i was just not playing
well so yeah i mean i had to say no i
think it was a good decision and i think
for the future it's it's uh
it's similar you have to try to to
to pick the tournament where where you
feel good
all right well gave your best shot and
best best of luck for next year thank
you a quick question for you linear
first of all nice going
undefeated if i got that right like
nobody and uh like you said you missed
opportunities
maurice has been asking
everybody takeaways from this event
events getting stronger obviously each
year it's like we're harder and harder
to win but for you what would you have
done differently coming into this event
yeah hard to say because uh
as i said i had so many chances i i felt
that i was
doing okay
opening wise i was getting good
positions with black i i didn't have
particular problems only in the first in
the first round but after that i was
just uh
having good positions frankly and uh
yeah i think i was just lagging energy
in the critical moments because um
to
it's clearly
a very strong tournament where people
defend very well
and and you just have to to push a bit
harder i guess uh in the critical moment
to win some games and i was just not
able to to do it
linear all the all the best to you and
much success in your future thank you
absolutely